Welcome organizers of connected data
London. I'm Joe Hilar, COO and one of
the co-founders of Enterprise Knowledge
and with me is
>> Bonoan, director of growth at EK.
>> As part of the presentation we'd like to
do at your summit, we are going to
present on the semantic layer. Back in
March of 2026, Gardner announced that
semantic layer was critical table stakes
for implementing AI in an organization.
Two months later, we published one of
the definitive books on the semantic
layer, bridging knowledge, data, and AI
for the semantic layer. As part of this
presentation, we're going to actually
explain what the semantic layer is, why
it's so important and critical for
making AI work and actually connecting
data across the enterprise and then talk
about how it's done including some of
the key components. Right, Benoa?
>> Yes. uh what we've seen in the semantic
layer is everyone is talking about this.
Some even think that's a product. We
have a totally different approach at EK.
We think it's actually more a framework
with different components to it that
would help organization to manage their
knowledge but also connecting it to
systems but also to people. Some of the
components uh are business glossery,
taxonomy, ontology, knowledge assets
which is a new concept that just really
remove the boundaries between structured
unstructured data. Think about all the
information that an organization has. um
as well as obviously a knowledge graph
that is bringing all these components to
life and that would allow uh an
organization to really create a web of
knowledge and information that people
and system can use on the day-to-day
operations. And more than just talking
about this concept in a real theoretical
fashion, we're also going to come with
actual real world success stories in top
tier organization global service uh
global financial service firm. We're
going to come with a story about global
retailer or um also of um investment
funds that have used this framework to
really boost their operation on a daily
basis.
>> Great. And at the end of this,
the people attending the conference
should be able to understand what the
semantic layer is, why it's critically
important to get the job done, and how
it can be used in their environment so
that they are better equipped to help
connect data in their organization.
Thank you.